Victor showed us how he can pull up a
list of links on a page using voiceover,
and even search through them.
This feature is obviously
most useful if, firstly,
the screen reader can find the links.
And secondly, if the actual text
of the links is meaningful.
For the first, there are three common
patterns that we see which can
cause the screen reader to
miss links in the page.
One is using a span,
with some link styling, or
an anchor tag without an href attribute.
This is popular for single page
applications when you have something
which is effectively an internal link.
Which does some javascript-based
navigation within the app.
Or also when you want something
which performs an action, but
looks like a link.
For anything which behaves like a link,
including within a single
page application.
You should absolutely use an anchor tag
with an href attribute, no exceptions.
You can read more about how to make
those links work nicely with smooth
single page app navigation
in the instruction notes.
But for now let's focus on what
it means for accessibility.
Not only will this make the link
show up in the links list, but
it will mean it automatically
works with the keyboard.
And that you can do things like copy or
bookmark the link location.
The second pattern is
the opposite problem,
something which is implemented using
a link but is really more like a button.
You can often recognize this by the href
attribute being something nonsensical.
For this case, we'll just replace
that anchor tag with a button tag and
style it appropriately.
In the next class,
we'll learn another technique for
making elements appear to have a
different role to assistive technology.
And the third example is where we
have an image used as link content.
For example, sometimes you might have
a piece of text which needs a very
specific style like a logo and
which is implemented as an image.
To the average sighted
user this works fine,
because they can still
understand what the link is for.
However for an assistive technology
this makes the link unusable.
We can fix that by using our usual alt
text technique to make sure the link is
experienced directly to
the assistive technology layout.
Just make sure the image has alt text.
So, that takes care of making sure
the screen reader can find the links.
But we also need to make sure that once
the link makes it into the links list,
that it's also useful.
We do that by making sure
its text is descriptive.
The checklist has a stronger and
weaker a version of this point.
The stronger one, item 2.4.9 states that
the purpose of each link should be able
to be determined from
the link text alone.
The Wikipedia example that Victor showed
had a lot of really useful link text
examples.
Because of the way a Wiki format
encourages creating links,
which use the page's
title as their text.
In general, link text should
give any user enough information
to decide whether they want to click it.
One common example of uninformative
link text we see a lot these days is,
learn more.
Usually this leads to a longer article
about the subject of the preceding
sentence or paragraph.
So one way we can make it more useful
for everyone is to rewrite the text to
say it something like, learn more
about responsive layouts in this case.
Or even making responsive layouts
the paragraph heading, the link.
This also means that,
if I'm visually skimming the page for
links, I don't need to backtrack
through the rest of the paragraph
to see what the link might be about.